In this lesson, the objectives are for us to now get a little bit more deeper
into understanding of how we can do simple image processing and filtering.
One of the things I'll be introducing you to today would be the concept of
cross-correlation that I've actually already introduced in previous lecture.
But now I'm going to try to define it much more accurately and mathematically.
Using that concept, we will look at the whole concept of convolution and
the relationship between convolution, and
cross-correlation will also be introduced in this lecture.
I will also describe some of the properties of how these types of methods can be
used to do filtering types of processes that we won't actually do to be able to
do computer vision and image processing on images.